it's the lightning and the gusty winds
that really make it dangerous and kind
of scary although i have to admit sure
did enjoy hearing the thunder didn't you
it was roaring yesterday well skies are
kind of a mix of clouds and sunlight
this morning and if you have rain clouds
and sunshine you get rainbows and again
i just want to share a couple more of
these great photos that you've been
sharing with us terry hernandez this
gorgeous shot yesterday of the rainbow
in the sky we got a lot of shots from
north las vegas but also in the
northwest and even on the east side so
thank you everybody who sent in your
photos we really appreciate it lots of
70s and 80s were more than 10 degrees
cooler temperature wise this morning
than we were yesterday remember the last
few mornings we've been in the 90s it's
been so warm but wow with those when
those thunderstorms hit yesterday around
boulder city henderson temperatures
dropped from triple digits into the low
90s even boulder city dropped into the
80s they're really cooling the rain when
it hits but then you've got that
fiercely hot lightning that's associated
with it too and that can be deadly so
dangerous that's why we really ask you
when you hear thunder to get indoors get
to a safe place it can be so dangerous
82 in mesquite 80 in pram in indian
springs 78 in boulder city 88 in
laughlin unfortunately officially again
we only picked up a hundredth of an inch
that's it this is where we are for the
year a little more than fifteen
hundredths of an inch and we should be
at two and a quarter inches for the year
now a lot of neighborhoods picked up
some nice healthy rainfall spring valley
over a quarter of an inch green valley
about a third of an inch and all around
boulder city anywhere from over a half
an inch to nearly an inch of rain
railroad pass out to the airport it's
just so many it was just inundated in
that area of focus those thunderstorms
but all in southern clark county too
some wonderful rainfall north las vegas
the northwest sides
sky canyon centennial hills
north las vegas even up to nellis just
didn't get that much rain those those
cells just kind of weakened as they kept
sliding north today could be focused on
north las vegas or the west side we'll
see high pressure still set up same
pattern in place and we're so juiced up
the atmosphere that we are looking for
the potential of thunderstorms in place
again today and again could be your
neighborhood today so fingers crossed
right now the radar is pretty quiet the
mountains looking for scattered
thunderstorms out to the lake lightning
gusty winds could be very dangerous to
be out on the open water so please watch
the skies if you can put it off for a
day or two until things are a little
clearer that would be safer we're
looking for 106 for the valley that
chance of isolated thunderstorms chance
for the mountains remains for the
weekend but the valley will dry out just
a little bit and stay very hot anywhere
from 107 to 109.